this is how to not approach girls at the
gym
there's mirrors everywhere so it's like
you can easily cat catch people
oh this is nothing
[Music]
exercise is just funny
five as five pounds
all right if he's like waiting in the
corner isn't there a pretty good
possibility he's maybe just waiting to
go onto this machine maybe he actually
is interested in talking to her and
asking her out on a date and he's
waiting for the right moment because
that's how it works when you meet people
you look at them you look at them first
and you wait until like you don't feel
awkward and then you go over and talk to
them you know it is not easy for men to
walk up and talk to women at any time
especially in today's times when these
young broads are so freaking angry and
they think the patriarchy is out to get
them I mean come on all right I want to
see what else this guy did that was so
terrible what's your question no as I
say these are the videos that we that we
see and then girls wonder why guys don't
want to talk to them or they're afraid
of some [__] happening who wants to talk
to her I'm gonna put on full makeup and
make sure my hair is Flawless and pick
out why do they wear outfit and then go
to the gym and then get mad when men
find me attractive okay all right why do
they wear shorts that are so tight you
can see their butt crack in them too
yeah no they walk around like she's
practically in underwear like 50 60
years ago that was undergarments you
don't wear that it is yeah it basically
is like when you go to the gym you don't
wear that [__] you wear like leggings
that are aren't like skin tight my
leggings my leggings are fitted they are
tight but I I'm not also wearing like a
bra and then getting mad when men look
at me yeah
yeah they they pick out clothes that are
sexy so like in the 80s and women you
got to look at like pop up some 80s
workout gear because some of it was was
tight but it was like a body suit and
leggings and some of it was like these
goofy ass sweatsuits that a woman like
you couldn't even tell she was a woman
under it yeah
I think this is a pick me outfit and
then you get mad when he picks you
he's just trying to meet you honey he is
only he's look at this guy he's like
there's a pretty girl and she also likes
to work out we have something in common
I'm gonna go try to be a gentleman and
help her even if he wasn't to you yeah
what's the big deal I know but that's
how I see this guy and maybe he's a
total [__] but he's not acting like
an [__] he's just going hey can I
help you out if a girl walks over and
said hey can I help you out she might be
like yeah sure whatever then they [__]
about there's no chivalry like it's
he was literally helping her with the
with putting the weight on like what is
wrong with that like when I'm at the gym
with my friends we'll just do that for
each other like you want you don't want
to be bothered don't do your hair don't
put on makeup put on a baggy t-shirt and
some sweatpants and make your outside
look like you're horrible inside oh
a little too honest tonight what if I
just ripped his pee pee out of its
socket so he could never reproduce this
is why I don't want kids natural
selection better take these this is why
I don't want kids what does this have to
do with that at all and imagine a guy
said anything about like doing some
something horrible physically to a woman
he'd be in jail like that's not even
this this is this is a woman privilege
we were just talking about you can say
[__] like this about men because it's
obviously unrealistic natural selection
better take these weirdos out he's going
to jail for staring at her under age 21
year old this has to be satire to an
extent like she has to just be like a
good marketer it's so stupid I feel like
she has to just be a good marketer and
understand that saying some dumb [__]
like this is gonna get under so many
people's skin that the video is going to
go viral and then her personal brand
just blows up more so this girl has just
for my I feel like that's what it has to
be is a well-known streamer I mean like
she's she's apparently she had an only
fans apparently she hadn't only fans but
I didn't see it in her Buy if she had an
only fans I feel like now would be the
time she'd be plugging it but she's not
so I don't know she's missing missing
opportunity maybe she really is just a
dumbass I include her
kindness so include kindness in her Tick
Tock like hey dude I'm filming for tick
tock say hi to the camera like make it
nice instead of being a [__] he's not
doing anything wrong
nope nobody no no we don't see what you
mean we think you are mean
oh God be careful
be [__] careful no you got to get a
personality
you are the problem
if you're gonna wear booty shorts that
are basically underwear how are you
possibly going to be surprised that
anybody looks at you it's not even like
it's it's guys having bad intentions
like it's just literally like there's a
butt right there but it's just nature
like this if this is a single guy and he
sees a woman that he's attracted to what
is wrong with him coming over and saying
hello Yeah but like if there's a good
looking guy there with his shirt off in
a six-pack you're acting like girls
aren't gonna like look check him out too
and and and hope he comes over to say hi
yeah exactly you know what I look took a
look at that guy he was just looking at
her like waiting for a chance to talk to
her he tried to talk to her she wasn't
interested that doesn't make him a creep
because you're not interested in him you
know it's something interesting so like
you know like you only want to adopt the
thinking of people you like feel some
sort of affinity to or even just people
that you you look up to a sense like
imagine we all just adopted this girl's
logic like with like the I don't want
kids like all these girls that they're
like I don't want kids like imagine
everyone thought like you like the world
would just be over in 80 years we'd just
be done what was the this is why I don't
want kids like how did that like I I no
but I just don't let's try to figure out
how but this is a big thing the girls
like I don't want kids like what's up
with that like that's your like what the
[__] that's the point of humanity is to
keep like spreading like if that wasn't
the point then it would end in 80 years
it would be over so it's like all right
like and then you're gonna go off
because they've been told that they're
all gonna be president and save the
world and that their career matters more
than anything and they don't realize
like I can tell you Bar None there's
nothing even close the best thing in the
whole world that has ever happened to me
is you obviously
foreign
even if it weren't as obvious to you
okay there was nothing that I can ever
accomplish or achieve that will even
measure up to the love and affection
that I feel for you thank you like truly
truly no matter how how much I can
ultimately hopefully I appreciate it put
forth and bring to this world nothing is
better than you to me nothing and so it
is sad to me that these women just write
it off and you know it to her it's more
important to get likes on Tick Tock
we're we're in a weird place we really
are humanity is in a weird spot
and put the weight on what was so
distressing about that
looking at you waiting for a moment when
he could have a sec to talk to you
oh really
wow God [__] you girl and I'll tell you
why you don't even know what it's like
to feel unsafe do you know how many
women are being trafficked prostitutes
who are who are injected with drugs
every day to go out and do their jobs
young girls with abusive parents that's
unsafe a guy looks at you when you feel
unsafe you know what just go lock
yourself in a room because you're not
good at life go the base mother's on
your ass no keep it moving what is this
what now this February we're partnering
up with a Navy SEAL friend of ours Tom
Shea hosts a 21 day virtual event that
you guys can join with us Tom is going
to teach you how to listen to your mind
in a new way and how to control it so
that you can have the discipline you
need to build the life you want whether
it's working out your relationships your
money your spiritual growth this is a 21
day virtual event where you get to learn
how to kill the excuses in your head and
you get to learn some discipline and
those are things that's how successful
people get successful best part is when
you come in through us you get a
discount on the enrollment so use code
sunny 25 is 50 to get 50 off the event
you will not regret it you will be a
changed person at the end of it do not
miss this so if you're interested
becoming a reformed human an absolute
animal go to tomshey.com and use Sunny
fast50 for 50 off of this program
another dumb broad well I don't even
know actually let's see yeah don't be
fair don't be judging
oh booty shorts and half naked again no
she's not those are not booty shorts
they're tight
what happened nothing happened
oh this one's bad this one's
um may I help you like do we got a
problem you looking at me
there was so much out of context there
so the guy's paced in a little which
people do in between sets and in between
you know cardio and weightlifting and
whatnot again
yeah I was just thinking this oh that it
was like like cotton balls on the end of
the on the end of that I don't want to
say it because everyone starts somewhere
funny because I even thought it and I
didn't want to say it and I didn't want
to be a jerk either because it's like
everyone does start somewhere you know
I'm not lifting like [__] Joey swole
out here but um it is it is pretty funny
it almost seems like you're obviously a
beginner you're obviously like a
beginner at the gym like this chick like
what happened here that is so creepy to
you a guy walked by watched you lifting
weights your form maybe found you
interested maybe he was looking at your
form maybe you checked out your ass in
the meantime so what if you don't want
your ass checked out wear baggy
sweatpants I'm sorry isn't that the
whole like point that these girls want
to get it don't they all want to get a
nice ass so then why are you mad that
people look but then what they ask for
themselves for themselves oh you're
right nothing to do with anybody looking
at them and going that's not a great ass
that was pretty racist of me all right
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure to like subscribe follow me on
Instagram at sunnyfaz and I'll see you
later
[Music]